nine North will have three definite and
two possible discharges 8 am at the
Royal free hospital in London nursing
and Ward managers decide who can get an
operation today based on what beds are
available
we can go ahead with all IQ cases
Ahmed the theater manager has news for a
patient on the seventh floor
Peter Gibson is getting his tumor out
today how's your carabin my care is
Phoenix aventory
um I really believe I've got lots of
friends who are in the NHS
um I think they deserve a lot more than
they're asking for
um and that the people who hold the
purse strings in the government I think
think is playing God
scalpel please Peter's surgery went well
the Royal free has the largest
neuroendocrine tumor service in the UK
and does the most operations in the
country on complex tumors in the gut
doctors here say they kept cancer
surgery going during the covered waves
but the virus has left a legacy the
footprint that covid's left on the work
we're doing now is is still real and
pretty immense we've got a huge backlog
primarily of patients waiting to have
surgery for benign conditions yeah so
unfortunately we are and we have seen a
lot of patients presenting with very
Advanced disease yeah so it's that delay
of getting into the system absolutely
it's backed talking two years ago yes
yeah that is certainly playing a part
statistics show Nationwide a thousand
more people are dying every week than
expected the excess death rates have
left questions about the impact of cuts
and covid on hospital care
it's not just delays in operations but
pressures on Emergency Care ambulances
and a e now add to that strikes by staff
the NHS can be a bottomless pit of money
but more money would be great I think
striking is currently the only way that
our salmon nurses and obviously other
sectors of society have got to make our
feelings known to the government what
sort of wasted times so the longest
waiting time we have in a e is 27 hours
for an 84 year old gentleman who's been
waiting for a medical bed this was an
extra area added during colvid to
account for capacity but since the
hospital doubled the space of its
emergency department during the virus
demand has not abated that strain on the
a e departments across the country yes
has led to questions about whether
that's responsible for excess deaths do
you think that that's a factor as a high
risk because we're seeing higher volumes
of patients they're more frail they're
more unwell they're sicker and we're
doing that with the same amount of
resource and the same amount of stuff so
the the clinician needs to Patient ratio
has widened greatly so there's the
potential for that happening quite
easily what's your message to whoever's
listening
I think a lot of the things that we're
focused on is we have no beds there's a
lot of delayed discharges from the
hospital things like social care and
because of that despite creating some
bed areas in corridors sometimes there
still isn't room in the last couple
months we were seeing patients at the
back of the ambulances so they'll have
their blood tests done the ambulance
crew had been really helpful taking the
patients to have their scans but they'll
have to come back onto the ambulance
those could have been up to six seven
hours on the ambulance before they
actually got a bed space and so that's
improving now it's improving but the
people problems and pressure keeps
piling through these doors and now it's
Junior doctors being balloted on strike
action the skill and commitment here is
without question but it can't be taken
for granted Jason Farrell Sky News